how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and we just got one division episode
eight
and wow this episode was not quite what
a lot of people were expecting
however it was extremely important as to
what is happening
in one division and we learned a lot
about wanda's backstory
including the fact that she was actually
a witch and had powers before coming in
contact with the infinity stone
i guess i should mention spoilers for
one division episode 8 but i imagine if
you clicked
on this video you don't really care that
much or you've watched the episode
now as i mentioned this episode was very
important and leads up to the finale
which
is going to be the next episode and a
lot was revealed that i'm going to break
down
and there's some key things that we need
to talk about here like who quicksilver
actually is how wanda got her chaos
magic powers in the first place what i
believe to be a
magneto easter egg and of course talk
about how there's a villain that's even
bigger than agatha harkness and why
agatha is
terrified of this villain now i'm going
to start off by breaking down some of
the key
moments that you need to know of the
episode what they mean
in my theory of what is actually going
to happen in one division
then of course we'll do a frame by frame
breakdown of the entire episode of one
division of course if you're new and you
love one division be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest marvel videos
so this entire episode was really about
one thing
agatha harkness trying to find out how
exactly wanda
did everything that happened how did she
create this fake reality how did she
change the reality how did she control
all of these people this is what agatha
wants to know and her being a
very very powerful witch as we saw in
the very beginning of this episode
is kind of baffled at how powerful wanda
actually is
now something to note here is that
agatha actually didn't know wanda
she just noticed her spells as she
mentioned in the episode
agatha said that she sensed this place
talking about westview she said she
sensed
the afterglow of so many spells cast all
at once
and she said that she couldn't make
heads or tails of it
and this is really saying something
because if you recall the opening scene
she overpowered a lot of different
witches including her mother
who was the head witch and possible
goddess of witchcraft which we'll talk
about in just a bit
but agatha knows her witchcraft and
she's extremely powerful yet
wanda kind of baffles her wanda's magic
baffles her and agatha
kind of starts to explain this agatha
compares
her witchcraft to wanda's witchcraft she
says wanda had thousands of people under
her thumb
she had complex storylines filled out
she had a witchcraft going for miles and
miles she says that wanda has every
single detail of this illusion down to
the crown
molding while expressing that it took
her years and years to master even very
simple spells like illusion
and transmutation agatha is baffled here
and she wants to figure out how wanda is
doing everything so she begins to take
wanda through her past all with the
purpose of trying to find out how wanda
did everything
and it doesn't seem like all of this was
due to the infinity stone agatha doesn't
really think that's
that big of a deal she casually says so
you came in contact with an infinity
stone that amplified your powers
powers that were already there and then
she says she has a theory but she needs
more evidence she gets a little bit
closer and says
tell me how you did it again demanding
to know how
wanda exactly did everything because she
doesn't really know how wanda is this
powerful
but then at the end she finally realizes
what wanda
is and we finally get the scarlet witch
name drop and we hear chaos magic
and this is what it really is all about
chaos magic and i believe this reveals
the next
big bad of the marvel cinematic universe
chaos magic is a magic that was believed
to be
so powerful it was thought to be
non-existent even the sorcerer's supreme
thought that it was made up
this magic can reconstruct realities
manipulate them
warp them it can change the very fabric
of existence
which is actually what we've seen wand
do but it can actually bring total
destruction to the cosmos
affecting not only the earth but the
entire universe
now this magic came from originally the
elder god an
arch demon chithon he used this magic to
rule earth as the god of chaos
and eventually his rule ended but all of
the mages got together on earth and they
decided to spread
a lie they said there's no god of chaos
and there is no
chaos magic and this is why agatha says
you're supposed to be a myth however
before chauthon was banished from the
earth dimension
he actually ran into wanda maximoff and
he touched her
or marked her and left her with a
fraction of his power
a fraction of his chaos energy and this
is what agatha harkness realizes
she heard the ancient myth so she knows
that must mean the elder god chathan is
real and a part of him
is left with wanda this is how wanda
truly got her chaos magic powers
not from the infinity stone but from the
elder gotcha thon
this is why she can use chaos magic
which means there is a possibility of
him returning to earth and i think we
might actually see this but i don't
think we're going to see this until
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness
so now the question is what are agatha's
plans
because i think one of two things are
happening here the first thing that
could be happening
is that agatha is truly scared yes she
is depicted as bad
but keep in mind that over 300 years
have passed since that opening
scene took place she may not be all that
bad anymore
and the reason that she came to west
view was to investigate the spells that
were happening
and now that she realizes it's chaos
magic the power of the elder god chithon
she fears for her life she fears for the
earth and the universe and needs to stop
wanda
because if you notice in her lair when
she's explaining
how long it took her to master simple
spells and how powerful
wanda spells actually are she looks
genuinely scared and then at the end
when she realizes what it actually is
she
again looks terrified and then the
second thing that could be happening
here is that she actually truly is
bad an evil witch and she's frustrated
that wanda
actually has such power frustrated that
she has chaos magic because it's very
clear from the opening scene that agatha
herself
dabbled in what we'll call the dark arts
this is why the other witches got
together to try and kill her because of
how powerful she was going to become
learning this dark magic so having
studied dark magic
and knowing what chaos magic is she may
actually try to summon chauthon for her
own purposes
either way it's very clear by what
agatha says it seems to be that wanda
has some of her powers because of this
elder gotcha thon and i believe that
this is going to be a big part
moving forward in the mcu specifically
with doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but let me know what you think
about this theory in the comments down
below
and now we'll break it down scene by
scene talk about the major things that
you need to know and break down
all the easter eggs so episode 8 starts
off in salem
massachusetts in 1693. now this is where
and also when the actual salem witch
trials took place in real life
in salem massachusetts between 1692 and
1693
more than 200 people were accused of
being witches
30 were found guilty and 19 of them were
executed by hanging
however the people who are hunting
agatha down are not humans accusing
witches of being witches but are
actually
witches accusing agatha of violating
their rules
they say that she stole knowledge above
her age and
station now agatha exists within a coven
of witches
and in their coven there is a hierarchy
and there are ranks that you have to
pass through
and the higher your rank the higher
magic you are allowed to learn
while the witches accuse agatha of
learning magic she was not yet allowed
to learn
which so happened to be the darkest of
magics they claimed that she broke their
rules but agatha
wittingly says i didn't break your rules
they simply bent to my power
admitting that she did in fact break the
rules now once she admits this the
witches decide that it's game over for
agatha or so at least they would think
and then they start to chant now they
appear to be saying
in latin moore's mantra naturai
and this is very interesting because it
ties into something that we've been
looking into this whole entire time
moors is actually the roman deity or god
of darkness
and agony moore's is also the
personification
of death and is often depicted having a
scythe in her hand now we've talked
about death and the grim reaper plenty
of times when it's come to wanda vision
we've had the grim reaper easter egg and
we've believed this whole entire time
that the brooch that agatha wears
actually has a scythe on it much like
the one that the grim reaper
or death would have and it's revealed
that she ended up getting this brooch
actually from her mother who she ended
up killing now the other part of the
chant seems to be
mantra which of course could be monster
and natori
could be natural claiming that agatha
could be a natural
monster now it's unclear on whether or
not they are actually calling her the
roman
god or goddess of death or if they are
calling upon
the god of death to kill her either way
it does seem like death is a part of
wanda vision in some way shape or
form now when her mother goes to kill
her we can see that there is a crown on
her head
now this could be an easter egg for the
goddess of witchcraft in the marvel
universe
however in the comics the goddess of
witchcraft was not agatha harness's
mother
and she was a god so the crown on her
head is more than likely just pointing
toward the fact that she is the head
of all of the witches there the queen of
all the other witches
side note this scene right here actually
sets up
dr doom his mother cynthia von doom was
actually a witch in a coven as well
she was very powerful and doctor doom
would go on to become one of the
greatest sorcerers of all time in the
marvel universe there's also a
connection between doom and mephisto and
i still believe the ultimate
main villain could be some amalgamation
of jathon
mephisto and nightmare all combined into
one we then go back to agatha's lair
where we left off in episode 7. and the
first thing that happens
is that her rabbit actually makes noise
like he's talking to her and she holds
him up and says
what's that like he really is talking to
her now perhaps this
could actually be something which is
what we've expected from the very
beginning since we've met senior
scratchy
agatha does have a son called nicholas
scratch who could somehow be the rabbit
my buddy brad lambert also has a theory
that perhaps this could be
doctor strange perhaps agatha ran into
doctor strange at some point in time
going for
wanda and her being the super powerful
witch that she is
turned him into a rabbit after all she
does mention transmutation
fun theory to think about not sure if
it'll actually happen but i think this
rabbit actually is a person which we'll
find out about eventually now wanda
tries to read agatha's mind but she
can't agatha is way too powerful and
experienced for wanda to be able to do
that
and here she explains actual witchcraft
wanda which wanda isn't that experienced
in
wanda doesn't realize that she is
actually a witch she still thinks she
got her powers from the infinity stone
which we now know is not accurate she is
indeed a witch and agatha expects her to
know all about spells she explains the
basic protection spells and how wanda
can't do magic
in the space where agatha did these
spells and she explains that there are
runes on the wall
and one of these runes glowing purple
looks an
awful lot like magneto's helmet and the
m for magneto
now we've been speculating for a long
time that in the marvel cinematic
universe
wanda's father could actually be magneto
this is a story straight from the comics
where wanda learns that the maximoffs
aren't her real parents but magneto is
in fact her dad
and perhaps magneto could be this secret
cameo appearing in the final episode
that we've been hearing about now as i
mentioned
in the beginning agatha's goal is to
know how wanda did
everything how she controlled all of the
people in west view how she cast
all these spells at once and we learned
that that's actually what evan peters
pietro was for
he was a product of agatha she was
possessing him and this explains why he
was always asking
her how she did everything because it
was actually agatha possessing him
wanting to know how she did it now she
does say that it actually wasn't her
just her eyes and her ears
it actually is a physical human person
and she says that she couldn't get her
actual brother because he wasn't on the
same continent
and he had a bunch of holes in him this
also explains as to why
vision was sometimes seen dead and
quicksilver was seen with bullet holes
on him that one time
this was agatha attempting to find out
more about wanda and how she created
everything she was trying to provoke
something inside of wanda
as she said she waited very patiently
but now she has to resort to simply
controlling her
and trying to get it out of her question
is is this the quicksilver from the fox
x-men universe and unfortunately i'm
kind of leaning towards
no i don't think it is i think that it's
a person that she plucked out of nowhere
and i think marva was being very clever
with the casting of evan peters
but i hope i'm wrong and i hope the
multiverse truly is opening up
now in one scene where agatha throws the
bird to a rabbit and the rabbit eats it
the rabbit is sitting on a table and on
that table
is a book that has a symbol of a tree on
it and this tree actually resembles the
tree that we see in captain america the
first avenger
where red skull finds the tesseract it
doesn't look exactly the same but it
does resemble it so this could perhaps
be some type of asgardian book
agatha is a witch that has been around
for a very very long time so i'm sure
she knows about asgardians
now again agatha just wants to know how
wanda did everything but
wanda has repressed all of her thoughts
and feelings and doesn't remember how
she did it she truly doesn't remember
doing it so agatha decides that it's
time to take a trip to her past
in hopes to awaken wanda's memories and
to hopefully see who wanda really is
and it starts with wanda as a child and
here is where we learn
why one division has been seen through
sitcoms
in sokovia wanda's father used to sell
dvds of
sitcoms in order to try and make money
this is revealed when her father comes
home with a suitcase full of dvds and he
says to his wife
don't worry i'll sell them all tomorrow
and if you take a look inside of the
suitcase we actually see the sitcoms
that we've been through in the one
division series
i love lucy bewitched malcolm in the
middle the addams family and who's the
boss
all of which we have seen in one
division bietro comes in and reveals
that the reason they do
tv night is so they can learn english
probably in preparation to move to a
country that speaks english
considering that their country is at war
it would make sense that the parents
would want to move the family away
the parents revealed that they're trying
to get rid of their sokovian accents
which is actually made fun of quite a
few times during monovision including
this episode where agnes says that
accent comes and goes
marvel fans have noticed that after age
of ultron juana's accent disappeared she
no longer had a sakovian accent
so this is kind of marvel's way of
making fun of themselves but also giving
us an explanation
now instead of little wanda coming out
wanda actually goes into the scene and
takes the place of her younger self
seeing it through her eyes when she was
young it's apparently her turn to pick
the show that they're going to watch and
she picks the dick van dyke show which
of course we've seen one division go
through in one of their sitcom eras
pietro even makes a statement that it's
sitcom sitcom
sitcoms always sitcoms with wanda which
explains why wanda's perfect
reality that she created was made inside
of a sitcom as they start the dick van
dyke show they're even in separate beds
like wanda and vision were in for the
first couple of episodes now
unfortunately as they are watching tv
and wanda is very much enjoying herself
their house is hit by a missile and we
finally see
the scene that wanda and pietro told
ultron in age of ultron how their
parents died and how a rocket landed in
front of them
and they just stared at it and on it it
said stark
this was originally why wanda and pietro
volunteered for hydra's experiments and
ultimately went on to fight with ultron
they wanted revenge on tony stark for
being the one who provided the missiles
that killed their parents
as the rocket sits there in their living
room a light on it beeps just like in
the commercial that we got for the stark
industry toaster
as they were waiting for the toaster to
pop and be ready the red light flashed
just like it did on this rocket now as
the twins are just staring at these
rockets the dick van dyke show is still
playing in the background
and the situation of the show suddenly
matches the situation of their real life
when you hear them say
oh i heard a scream oh i must have
screamed
dick goes on to say oh what a nightmare
which is exactly what wanda and pietro
were going through in that moment
a nightmare wanda tries to comfort
herself by saying and at the end of the
episode you realize it was all
a bad dream or a nightmare we then see
wanda reach out her hand
towards the missile but then agatha
pulls her out of there and here's where
our whole perspective on wanda actually
starts to change
agatha realizes that wanda was a witch
since the very beginning and wanda was
actually the one who stopped the bomb
from going off
using a probability hex although she
didn't know it at the time
she just thought that it never went off
she just thought it was defective but
really it was a probability hex
and thank you to one of my subscribers
alex majors for pointing out the fact
that nexus beans have the power to
affect probability
in one division episode 7 we got a
commercial for a nexus pill which we
believe
is referring to wanda being a nexus
being
agatha realizes that wanda is a witch
but she realizes that her powers aren't
that strong at this point in time
and they have to develop even further so
she asks wanda where did you get the big
guns when did you start to become
so powerful and that brings us to the
next scene where hydra does
experiments on wanda and vietro although
we don't see pietro again in age of
ultron we learned that wanda and pietro
volunteered to be experimented on they
did this because of the bomb that had
stark industries on it they wanted to go
and fight against him
so they volunteered for hydra all of a
sudden the door appears and the hydra
symbol is on it
we enter the door and see two hydra
scientists one of which i believe
could be struck her it is a different
actor from age of ultron but it's a bald
man and we know that strucker was the
one who experimented on wanda and bietro
there's also been of course the strucker
callbacks and the commercials that we
got in the one division series where we
had the hydra strucker watch
so even though it's a different actor
this is most likely struck her
and in the background we see loki's
staff one of the doctors says to begin
the experimentation and the other says
with respect not one subject
has survived direct contact meaning that
everybody else they did experiments on
died but they start the experiment
anyways now as wanda approaches the
staff
something very interesting happens the
infinity stone jumps out of the staff
and goes in front of wanda
it appears to no wanda and it looks as
if it's almost speaking to her and
what's even more interesting is that the
stone is
actually blue now when wanda gets close
enough to it and almost touches it it
kind of
explodes it's almost breaking its outer
shell and we see the actual mine stone
then it explodes but instead of
destroying wanda
it's held back by something and we find
out that it's actually being held back
by the scarlet witch now how i interpret
this
is this is actually wanda it's a
manifestation of who is inside of her
at this point in time she did not know
that she was a witch but clearly as
agatha states she is a scarlet witch and
this power
this scarlet witch inside of her is what
saved her
proof that this is actually a
manifestation to wanda and wanda only
is that when the doctors reviewed the
footage we actually didn't see the
infinity stone come out of the scepter
and go up to wanda this is something
that only she saw
then agatha adds she got up close and
personal with an infinity stone
and it amplified a power inside of her
that would have
died so essentially what happened here
is that the infinity stone
awakened the scarlet witch inside of her
and that's what we see here during this
explosion the explosion is kind of
taking place
inside of her then as wanda goes back to
her room we see her watching yet another
sitcom the brady bunch
again further explaining why one
division was originally a sitcom
it was all because of wanda's past but
this isn't good enough for agatha
contact with an infinity stone doesn't
explain why wanda is so powerful
but as agatha states she has a theory
and i believe that this theory
is wanda has chaos magic because she has
been marked by jathon
but agatha states that she needs more so
we head to the avengers compound after
the events of avengers age of ultron
here wanda talks about how alone she was
because she was in a new country and her
brother died but
she had what she always had a sitcom to
watch
this time she was watching malcolm in
the middle this series was
one of the series that was seen in her
father's briefcase of the dvds that he
was selling
so this most likely brought her some
comfort but ultimately brought her some
sadness making her think about her
family in the times they used to watch
tv together
here is where we see the relationship of
wanda and vision start to form wanda
actually
senses vision before he comes in the
room she calls for him and has him come
sit next to her and from here we
actually see a very surprisingly human
vision it seems like he's kind of
starting to understand feelings and
emotions this would explain why he a
synthezoid was able to actually fall
in love with wanda and it was through
interacting with her that he was able to
learn about these emotions
and he's surprisingly deep he even drops
the line on us but what is grief
if not love persevering and here is
where they truly start to bond and gain
feelings for each
other even agatha herself sheds a tear
but it's not enough for agatha she still
doesn't know how
wanda did everything so she pushes her
even further
telling her that everyone was gone but
she wanted vision
back and from here a door to the sword
facility opens up and we learn
the truth not the lie that hayward told
us but the actual truth now this appears
to be the same time that monica rambo
came back to working for sword as the
televisions on top
have the same news that they had when
monica rimba was walking into the sword
facility for the first time
they're all about people coming back
from the blip the snap
whatever you want to call it and
families reuniting and of course there
are celebrations happening everywhere
now wanda is actually trying to be
pretty civil here because she has the
capability to just burst in and
kind of overpower everybody but instead
she talks to the person at the front
desk and despite him
giving her resistance she says i know
vision is here but she
says that when she came back he was gone
and we know that hayward
took vision's body and is dissecting it
here at the sword facility so he can
actually make
weapons out of vision and wanda just
wants a funeral for vision and she also
wants it for herself because she wants
that closure and she feels that after
everything she's been through
she deserves that now eventually hayward
gets on the phone lets her in
not that she needed anybody to let her
in because she gets in by herself
anyways
but again trying to be a good citizen
and eventually goes and meets hayward in
his office
and here's where we learned that hayward
really is just the worst
jerk that you've ever seen he shows
wanda that they're disassembling
vision because he's the world's most
sophisticated
sentient weapon ever made after all
that's what sword
does they stand for sentient weapon
observation and response division and
hayward says that he can't let wanda
escape with three billion dollars worth
of vibranium and all he can do is let
her say goodbye to him here
wanda says he's all i have and hayward
says well that's just
it wanda he isn't yours and that sends
wanda
over the edge wanda breaks the glass
jumps down but instead of attacking
everybody
and taking vision's body she simply says
goodbye
she tries to sense him and feel him
which is a call back to avengers
infinity war during the beginning where
wanda and vision were in the hotel
together and wanda felt the infinity
stone inside a vision and said
all i feel is you now him being
dismantled and the mind stone not a part
of him
she can't feel him anymore but she
leaves she doesn't take vision's body
like
hayward told everybody else she did and
of course as we know from the
post-credits scene he did
reassemble vision as his own sentient
weapon
so it's very clear at this point in time
that he is a bad guy he's a villain
now is he just a jerk perhaps but he
could also be a scroll
we know that marvel announced the secret
invasion disney plus show which is the
story that revolves heavily around the
scroll
so perhaps hayward is a scroll and this
will lead into that disney plus series
and here's where we start to figure
everything out wanda has a letter in her
car which sends her to westview new
jersey
and we find out that westview really
isn't that great of a town
in fact it's pretty sad and the people
that are in it are
pretty sad as well it looks like most of
the businesses are going
out of business and we start to see the
normal versions of the characters that
wanda was controlling
we see herb walk down the street who
doesn't have an afro we then see norm
posting a flyer for learning piano
clearly everything in westview is in a
pretty bad financial state so he's
trying to make some money here
we see mrs hart who doesn't really seem
that happy in life
and really neither do any of the
citizens of westview it appears
wanda eventually finds herself arriving
at a lot where a home was apparently
built before
or was going to be built but it stopped
and it looks like
this was apparently going to be a gift
from vision to wanda
they were going to build a house here
and grow old together as vision writes
on his note
to grow old in v with a heart around it
this is what wanda and vision were going
to do
they were going to get away from it all
get away from the avengers
the superhero life they were going to
move to a small town and just
be together and wanda knowing this and
being on the property of where her
future house was supposed to be with her
husband vision
sends her over the edge and her chaos
magic explodes
and if you look at it it is different
magic from her than we've seen before
this is true chaos magic that we're
seeing and this is what took westview
and warped it into her own reality
remember chaos magic is the magic to
control
reality and she bases this new reality
off of the sitcoms that she loved
growing up now as she changes the
reality of west view we can see a
painting advertisement on the side of a
building that says
make cleaning up a snap obviously
referencing the snap that thanos did but
also referencing the fact that she
is cleaning up this town and turning it
into her new reality and this is an
advertisement for
lagos paper towels that we saw in a
commercial before lagos of course being
where wanda
accidentally killed people in captain
america civil war
we then see a theater change that reads
the tawnhasser gate which is a blade
runner reference and then it changes to
big red and kidnapped kidnap of course
because agatha harkness kidnapped her
sons
and then something very interesting
happens as wanda creates this reality
with her chaos magic
and recreates this town there is a
golden energy that flows out of her to
create
vision now the mind stone is what
powered vision and of course it was a
golden yellowish color as well
the mind stone is also what enhanced
wanda's abilities so it could be
energy from the infinity stone that is
with inside
wanda that is being used to create
vision here perhaps meaning that vision
may have some hope of surviving outside
of the hex after all now after the chaos
magic is done she arrives in her perfect
world set
in a sitcom reality where vision of
course is alive
and this is all agatha needs to see she
understands everything now
agatha disappears wanda hears her kids
crying and runs to them
where agatha has them very violently
might i add it looks like she's about to
rip their heads off
and here's where i talked about in the
beginning agatha knows who she is she's
the scarlet witch
she has chaos magic which is supposed to
be a myth that she probably got from
jathon
and it ends with her finally saying the
scarlet witch
but of course we have yet another post
credit scene in episode 8.
in episode 7 hayward talked about a
launch and as i mentioned in my other
breakdown i believe that it was going to
be a weapon
i actually believed it was going to be
another version of ultron and
as it turns out i was right they
recreated vision they said that they
took them apart and put them back
together a million times
but they couldn't find a strong enough
power supply that is until
wanda threw the drone back at him that
was seemingly charged with her power
and this power was enough to bring a new
vision
to life now this vision is a white gray
version of vision which is a callback to
the west coast
avengers vision and this new vision is
brought back to life but instead of the
mind stone in his head it almost looks
like he has
a tiny little arc reactor like tony
stark had in his chest
now remember when vision was originally
created he was supposed to be ultron
and now sword has rebuilt him as a
weapon and he doesn't have
the mind stone so this is essentially a
different version of ultron that sword
controls at least for the moment because
i don't think they'll be able to control
him for very long
now this sets up quite a big fight for
the finale we're gonna have ag of the
harkness and wanda
the vision that wanda created and the
vision that sword created
her twin boys hopefully and evan peters
quicksilver and
monica rambo which we didn't see in this
episode so it's all shaping up for a
pretty
big finale and it looks like we're going
to have a lot of fight sequences so
what did you think about wanna vision
episode 8
and what do you think we're going to see
in the finale let me know what you think
in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the one division
theories or
breakdowns don't forget to give the
video a like for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof
me